in this video we're going to learn about
the popular java testing framework
junit 5. we'll start off by learning how
to write basic unit tests using jn85
by taking a simple contact manager
application as an example
and step by step will cover all the
important features of junit 5.
by the end of this course you will have
a solid understanding of how to test
your java applications
using junit5
[Music]
[Applause]
so what is junit according to jnet
website it is a simple
open source framework to write and run
repeatable tests
jlit provides a simple api to test our
java applications
the class or method we want to test is
usually
called as subject under test so to write
a test we simply create a java test
class
and use the junit api to make some
assumptions towards the behavior
of the subject under test and then jade
verifies whether these assumptions
are correct or not by either passing or
failing the test
before writing our first test let's take
some time to understand the architecture
of junit 5.
on a high level junit 5 is basically a
combination
of three different modules jain platform
is the module which provides an api to
launch the test from either the ids
build tools or console so when you write
a unit test using junit
your ide or build tool or console
whatever platform
you're using uses this api inside the
jnet platform module to launch the tests
next we have the jnet jupiter module
which provides an api to write our jna
tests and
extensions in this course we are going
to mainly focus on this module because
if you want to write unit tests using
j.net5
this is the module you need the next
module is junit vintage which provides a
test engine implementation
to support backward compatibility for
tests written with
junit 3 and jnet4 so if you have some
tests which are written using chain
3 and 4 you can use this module to
execute the stress without rewriting
them in jn85
and lastly jnet platform module enables
some third-party testing frameworks to
build their own
api to write the tests and reuse the
junit platform module to launch these
tests
so this is another interesting update
which is part of junit 5.
now let's go ahead and write our first
test using junit 5
so to write the unit test we are going
to use a contact manager application
i already prepared before as the name
suggests this application manages the
contact information and this is a very
simple application
which contains only two java classes the
first one is a simple pojo class which
contains three fields
first name last name and phone number
and the next class is named contact
manager
so this is responsible to store the
contact information
here we have a method named add contact
where it takes
the first name last name and phone
number as input parameters
and then storing the information in
memory using a concurrent hash map we
are using a concurrent hashmap because
it's a thread safe implementation of the
map interface
so as part of adding the contract we are
performing some additional operations
like checking whether the contact
already exists or not and validating the
contact information based on some
business rules so we have a method to
validate each field in the contact class
so if we open the contact class we have
a method
which validates the first name so it is
basically checking whether the first
name is blank or not that means it
checks whether
it's not null and not empty we are doing
the same validation
also for the last name and four number
fields but for the phone number field
we are doing some additional validations
such as we are checking that the phone
number should be exactly ten digits in
length
and it should contain only digits and it
should start with
zero so once all these validations are
passed successfully
we are storing them in memory this is a
very simple application but provides
enough functionality to cover all the
features of junit 5.
if you want to download the source code
have a look at the link in the
description and you can also have a look
at the written version of this tutorial
by checking the blog
article i have linked this also in the
description section to follow along the
tutorial i suggest you to
download the source code for the starter
project from the link in the blog post
where you will start with a clean slate
without any tests
and gradually by the end of this course
you will reach to the state of the
completed project
i am using intellij idea as my primary
ide for this course
and the start project is using maven as
a project management tool
if you are not aware of the 40s maven i
have a comprehensive video tutorial
called maven complete tutorial in my
youtube channel
have a look at it i will also leave the
link in the description section
so to start off first we need to
download jnet5 into our project
for that instead of downloading the jar
manually and adding it to the project
i'm going to take the help of maven to
automatically download the jar file
whenever it's needed to be able to do
that maybe need some information so that
it can download the java file
automatically we call this jar files as
project dependencies
so these dependencies can be defined
inside the palm.xml file and inside the
file i'm going to add a tag called as
dependencies
and under that i'm going to provide the
dependency information by typing the
group id as org
jn8 jupiter artifact id as jlo jupiter
and version as 5.7.0 so this is the
information maven needs to download your
dependencies
these are also called as artifact
coordinates i'm just giving the bare
minimum information about maven
if you need more details have a look at
the video tutorial again so once i type
these details we need to ask
intellij to force maven to download
these dependencies
we can do that by clicking on the maven
icon on the top right corner
that's all you need to download the jne
jupiter dependency to our project
now let's go inside the source test java
folder again this is the maven
convention
folder structure to store the test
classes and inside the java folder
i'm going to create our contact manager
test class
so you know what uh let me show a
shortcut to do this automatically
so from contact manager class so let me
open the contact manager class
and inside this class just make sure you
selected the editor section then press
the key combination ctrl shift t
then you should see a small pop-up
window which which asked whether to
create the test or not so i am going to
select that option
and click on ok and intellij
automatically creates the test class
called
menu contact manager test for us inside
the class i am going to create a method
called as should create contact
the jna tests are nothing but methods
inside the test class
so janet identifies a method as a test
when we add the test annotation
on top of the method by adding this
annotation junit understands this is a
test
and starts executing it when we run this
class so if i try to run this class with
the empty test method
you will see that it executes
successfully because we didn't add
anything to the method
so now let's go ahead and add some test
logic inside the method so basically we
want to test that a contact is created
successfully so for that
first i need to create an object for the
contact manager class
and after that i'm going to call the add
contact method
inside the contact manager and i'm going
to pass in the first name
last name and phone number details as
input
so if you go inside the implementation
we are storing the contact information
inside the map
and we have a method called as get all
contacts where we are reading all the
contacts present inside the map so to
verify whether the contact is created or
not i am going to call this method
and make sure that the contact
information exists inside the list or
not so back to the class class
i am going to call the get all context
method and as a first step i want to
verify that the list is not
empty so this process of verifying our
expected output with the actual output
is called as
assertions so and janet provides an
assertion class and inside the class i
am going to make use of the
asset false method so this method will
take a boolean parameter as input and if
the boolean is not false
it will throw an exception and will fail
the test so as we expect this list from
get all contacts method should not be
empty
i use the assert faults method next i am
going to make sure that there is exactly
one element
inside this list i can perform this
assertion by using the asset equals
method from the assertions class this
method takes the expected value as the
first parameter
and the actual value as this has the
next parameter so i am going to
call the size method of the list written
by the get all contacts method so now
it's time to run the tests
i'm going to click on the green button
to the left side of the class
declaration and click on run test
and you can see that the test is
executed successfully
so we saw how to test a happy path
scenario we added a contact and the
contact information is saved to the
application
now let's go ahead and test a negative
scenario where the contact creation is
failing
so we can test this case by providing
some invalid input to the add contact
method if we open the validate contact
method
inside the contact manager class we are
validating the first name
last name and phone number fields so now
let's go ahead and add a test
where we are providing invalid values to
all these fields so i'm going to open
the contact manager test class
and i'm going to create three methods
inside the class
to test the case of invalid input of
first name
last name and phone number fields if you
provide an invalid input the application
should throw a runtime exception
so and here you may observe that i added
a new annotation called
display name this annotation as the name
suggests provides a custom readable name
to your test
so instead of displaying the method name
which is sometimes not so readable
junit displays this custom name in the
test results
so inside the first test method we are
verifying if the add contact method
throws a runtime exception
when the value of the first name fail is
null for that of course we have to
provide the first name as null
and we are verifying whether the runtime
exception is thrown or not with the help
of assets throws method from the
assertions class
this method takes the type of the
exception we are expecting so that in
our case it is
runtimeexception.class and as part of
the second parameter we have to provide
the supplier
where we are calling the add contact
method so when i run the test again
you can see that all the three threads
are executed successfully
if i open the other tests you can see
that i am passing the value null
for last name and as well as four number
fields
so now that we wrote a few tests let's
go to some theoretical aspects of junit
and understand
how the jv test life cycle works so each
junit test
when it is executed will create a new
instance of the test class
and it follows different phases as part
of the execution
each phase is also represented with an
annotation in jnet5
the first phase is before all phase
where the methods which are marked with
this annotation
will be executed before any of the test
methods inside the test class
the second phase is the before each
phase where the methods marked with this
annotation will be executed
before each of the test methods inside
the test class
and the third phase is the after each
phase where the method will be executed
after each test method inside the test
class and finally we have the after all
phase
where some logic will be executed after
all the test methods inside the class
are executed
so the main use of these lifecycle
phases is you may want to run some
initialization tasks or some cleanup
tasks
when running the tests some general
examples of this include
setting setting up or creating test data
inside the database
at the start of the tests and cleaning
them up after the test execution
so now let's go ahead and see how we can
implement these methods inside our
contact manager test class the first one
is the before all annotation
as i said before the method marked with
this annotation will be executed once
for the entire test class and usually
this occurs before creating the instance
of the test
for this reason we have to mark the
method as
static or else jnet cannot execute this
method
so inside this method i am going to
print a message so
which should print this message before
all the tests are executed
and now if i run this test class you
should see that the message is printed
before the tests are executed
so i just created a method and added the
before all annotation and this message
is
is printed when at the time of test
execution now let's add the before each
annotation
i'm going to create a method called as
setup and add the before each annotation
to this method
and inside this method we are going to
initialize the contact manager class
you can observe that inside all the test
methods we are creating the object for
test
for contact manager class this is
redundant so we can move this logic
inside the setup setup method so i am
going to remove the contact manager
instantiation part from all the tests
and i'm going to create a class variable
contact manager and assign the variable
to the contact manager object
inside the setup now you may think that
we are using only one contact
manager object for all the tests inside
the class is not true
jnet will create a new instance of the
class for each method
so each test will work with its own copy
of the test contact manager object so
now if we try to run the tests again
we can see that the tests are executed
without any side effects
the same applies also for the after
reach and after all annotations
so i quickly created a couple more
methods and inside this method we are
just printing some messages
but if you are working with a more
complex setup usually you will clean up
the test data created as part of the
part of the test inside either of these
methods as i mentioned before jnet
instantiates the test for each test
method
but we can also change this behavior so
that it will create only one instance of
the class
by adding the test instance annotation
to the top of the class
and to this annotation we can provide
the value lifecycle
dot per class by adding this annotation
junit instantiate the test class only
once
in this case we can remove the static
keyword
for the after all and before all methods
the next feature we are going to discuss
is the conditional execution feature in
jvnet
we can execute the test methods in our
class based on a specific condition
for example imagine if you developed a
specific functionality
on linux machine for our contact manager
application
which is after saving the contact maybe
we are performing some additional logic
which is specific to the linux operating
system then we have to make sure that
the test should only run when it's
running
on the linux operating system or else
it's pointless to run the test
to enable this jnet provides us with
annotations enabled
on os and disabled noise and to this
annotations we can pass on the operating
system name as the annotation parameter
so i copied one of the existing test
methods and i'm going to add the enabled
on os annotation on top of the
method and i'm going to specify the
value as
mac from the os enum and we can specify
a message by providing an input
to the disabled reason field so let me
copy the test again
and this time i'm going to add the
disabled on os annotation
and specify the value as windows because
i am using the windows operating system
and if i try to run the test now
you should see that both these tests are
disabled and actually
it's not clear which test is visible so
i am going to change the method name
and display names and if you run the
test again you can see that
the both these tests are disabled and we
are able to differentiate which one is
actually disabled
the next feature we are going to learn
about is assumptions these are similar
to conditional executions annotations
but
instead of executing the test
conditionally we are going to perform
the assertions inside the test
conditionally
that means if the assertions is not if
the assertion is not successful then the
test won't fail
but it will be aborted and won't be
executed further
for example you may have some unit tests
which you may have some tests which you
want to run only on the developer
machine but not on cia enrolment or
maybe some long running tests which you
want to execute
based on a condition so in this case the
test execution will simply be aborted
if the if the criteria for the condition
is not met
so let's see how to do this in practice
so i'm again copying the existing test
and i'm going to rename it as should
test contact creation on dev machine
and also change the display name and
inside the test before executing the
actual test i'm going to read the system
property
called env this is the property which i
have set inside the
run configurations for the test so
inside intellij
i'm going to edit the run configuration
and add the property to the vm options
so you can see that i had a decision
property with minus
with prefix minus d so in the test i'm
going to read this property and after
reading this i am passing it as a
parameter
to assume true method so this is the
method from the assumptions class
which takes in a boolean parameter there
is also an assume
false method which also takes a boolean
parameter but in our case we will use
the
assume through method to perform some
assumption and if you
execute the test now you should see that
the test is passing and now let's
quickly change the property to another
name so instead of
checking whether the property is def
let's change it to test
and if you run the test again now you
can see the message assumption failed
but the test is not failing it is just
aborted
the next june 85 feature we are going to
learn about is the repeated tests
so in some situations you may need to
run a specific test case multiple times
maybe because the functionality has a
bit of randomness to it
imagine you are generating a random
number between range maybe 1 to 10 or 1
to 50
and in those cases you may you you can
say to junit to repeat the test
execution for a certain number of times
we can do that by using the repeated
test annotation so this is just like a
substitution for the test annotation
but the test method will be executed for
multiple repetitions
so in our contact manager test we are
not dealing with any random
functionality so this is not a very good
example for this use case but we can
still apply the repeated test annotation
to check whether the test method is
executed for multiple repetitions or not
so let's take the contact creation test
again and i'm going to rename it
and add the repeated test annotation on
top of the method by adding this
annotation we can remove the test
annotation
and to to the repeated test annotation
we can pass in the value
for how many times we want to that we
want the test to be repeated
so i want this test to run for five
times so i'm going to pass in this value
and now if i run the test
you can see that these uh you can see
the custom name for the repeated test
like repetition 105
205 and so on we can also provide a
custom name for these repeating tests
so instead of just displaying repetition
105 we can make it more descriptive by
passing the name field to the repeated
test annotation
and here i'm going to pass the value for
name as repeating contact test and we
want to know what is the count of the
current repetition so for that we have
the current repetition and total
repetition values if we specify these
values inside the curly brackets
junit automatically fills in this value
for these fields at runtime
so if we execute the test now you can
see the value repeating contact creation
test
105 to a 5 and so on
so now let's learn about how to write
parameterized tests in jnet
parameterized tests are similar to
repeated tests but the difference is
you can run the test repeatedly by
giving different set of inputs
to our tests similar to repeated tests
we can replace the test annotation
about the test method with the
parametrized test annotation after
adding the annotation we need a way to
submit
different set of inputs to the test
method we can do that with the help of
some other annotations which is used
together with the parameterized test
annotation so
the first one is the value source
annotation by using this annotation we
can provide the input directly as a
parameter value
to the annotation and the value source
annotations support different types of
literal values like
strings hint double float etc so you can
see the complete list of supported
values on screen
in our case we need only random strings
to test the contact creation
and we want to see if the validation for
phone number field is working or not by
providing different range of inputs so
remember that we are doing some specific
validation for the phone number field
first we are checking if the phone
number is not null and not empty then we
check the length is exactly 10
characters long we are making sure that
the given string contain only numbers
and lastly we are checking whether the
phone number
is starting with zero so to test all
these cases usually you have to write
multiple tests to verify each criteria
but using parameterized tests you can
provide different set of inputs and test
them in only one test case so back to
the test class i copied the contact
creation test again and changed the name
and the text inside the display name
annotation let's add the parameterized
test
and value source annotation to this test
method and i'm going to provide some a
list of
strings which contains some random
numbers as the input to be able to use
these values inside our test
we need to provide a string variable as
a parameter to the method
and j init then will automatically
inject this value into the method while
executing the test
and lastly we have to make sure that
instead of hard coding the value
i am passing the phone number variable
to the add contact method and now if i
run the test you can see that the test
is passing because i provided all the
values which are valid so i'm going to
change one of the values here and
provide an invalid value so i'm going to
add a plus symbol in front
and run the test again this time the
test is failed because it's failing the
validation that the phone number should
be
exactly 10 characters long
the next way to provide input for the
parametrized tests is by using the
method source annotation
now you may have already observed that
we are a bit limited to what input we
can pass to the test
using the val value source annotation in
the real world the test data
requirements are not so straightforward
and
we may have to construct some complex
objects as the test data and pass them
to
our test for that reason we can use the
method source annotation where we can
refer a method inside the test class
which is responsible to create the test
data and this data is then injected into
our test let's see how to do that
back inside the test class i am going to
create another parametrized test this
time with method source annotation and
i'm going to create a method called
phone number list
which is returning a list of phone
numbers inside the test class
i'm going to just copy the method name
and pass it as an argument to the method
source annotation and now if you run the
test
jnet will dynamically read the data
returned from the method
and will inject them into the tests so
there is no need to change the test
implementation and let's go ahead and
run the test so you can see that all the
tests are passing successfully
and if you're wondering how the previous
test is passing again i just change the
inputs to
some valid inputs inside the value
source annotation
so the next annotation we're going to
use for the parameterized test is the
csv source annotation using this we can
declare the input data as csv literals
in our tests so if you're not aware of
what is csv it's called as common
comma separated values so as the name
suggests we are going to pass the input
as a list of comma separated strings so
back to the test class i'm going to
create another test called as should
test phone number format using csv
source and change the display name text
and i'm going to add the csv source
annotation
and to this annotation i'm going to pass
the valid list of phone numbers
as comma separated strings so it's a
pretty straightforward and if i run this
test you can see that the test passed
successfully without any errors
and the last annotation are going to
talk about for the parameterized tests
is the csv file source annotation this
is very similar to csv source annotation
the only difference is instead of
referencing the list of comma separated
strings directly inside the code we are
going to provide the
reference of the csv file directly to
the csv file source annotation so this
file is usually located inside the
resources directory of the test folder
in the maven folder structure so i'm
going to create a file called as
data.csv and inside the file i'm going
to just copy and paste the data we
passed to the csv source annotation and
if i go back to the test i am going to
create another test method for this case
and inside the csv file source
annotation i am going to
assign the csv file name to the res to
the resources field now let's run the
tests again
and they should be passing without any
issues
the next generate feature we are going
to learn is the nested test
so as the name suggests we can nest or
group some tests inside our contact
manager test class
into an inner test class so in our
example we have multiple test methods
which can be grouped together
this may be some repeated tests or the
parameterized test because they belong
to the same
category and if we organize these tests
into their own classes then the task
class will look much more clean and well
organized so this is the main reason for
using the nested class to make the test
more organized so i'm going to quickly
create two classes
repeated nest test and parameterizedness
test
inside the contact manager test class
jn8 understands these are nested test
classes by the nested annotation so i'm
going to add this annotation on top of
both these classes so the life cycle of
nested test class is a bit different
than the normal test class
in the nested classes we are allowed to
only use the before each and after each
annotations
but not before all and after all because
java won't allow
static members inside the inner classes
however if you want to use the before
all and after all annotations
you can change the instance life cycle
by adding the test instance annotation
with life cycle value as per class okay
now back to the test class and i am
going to simply cut and paste the
parameterized tests
into the parameterized nested test class
and the repeater test into the repeated
nested test class
apart from the change in the structure
of the test there is nothing changed in
the code so this change should not
introduce any side effects for the test
execution so let's verify this behavior
by running the test again
and you can see the tests are passing
without any errors
now let's discuss the last junit
annotation of this course
that is the disabled test you can use
this annotation to disable some tests
from executing in our test suite so it's
not generally encouraged to use this
annotation
until it's really necessary because
there's a chance that you will forget to
remove the annotation after adding it
and the test will be disabled forever
which is not so good so to demonstrate
this i am going to
add this annotation to the first contact
creation test we
added and if i run all the tests after
that you can see that
the first test should con should create
contact
is disabled so
so this is the end of this tutorial
thank you very much for watching this
and i will see you in the next tutorial
until then happy coding techies